Nos dicen que: "Keyla quiere visitar a una amiga
que vive a 8 kilómetros de distancia. Ella viajará
en el metro tan lejos como pueda antes de caminar
el resto del trayecto. Primero, necesita comprar
un pase de acceso que cuesta $5.50 [dólares].
También hay una tarifa de $1.25 [dólares]
por parada", este es un metro caro. "Keyla no
quiere gastar más de $15 [dólares] en el viaje,
así que quiere saber cuál es el mayor número de
paradas que puede pagar. Usa S para representar
el número de paradas que Keyla puede comprar".
Primero pausa este video y trata de escribir
una desigualdad que describa la situación, que
describa que ella quiere tomar el mayor número
de paradas sin gastar más de 15 dólares. Muy
bien, ahora hagamos esto juntos. Para empezar,
pensemos en una expresión para lo que
ella gasta, entonces, pase lo que pase,
va a gastar 5.50 dólares, podemos escribirlo
de esta manera: $5.50 dólares, eso es lo que
va a gastar incluso si no se detiene; cada parada
cuesta $1.25 dólares, y S es el número de paradas,
así que la cantidad que va a gastar sólo por las
paradas va a ser $1.25 dólares por S, de modo que
escribimos + 1.25 dólares S. Este es el dinero
que tiene que gastar inicialmente y esto es lo
que va a gastar por las paradas. Sabemos que no
quiere gastar más de $15 dólares, está dispuesta
a gastar hasta $15 dólares, entonces esta cantidad
total que ella gasta tiene que ser menor o igual a
$15 dólares. Si no lo escribimos con un signo de
dólares, escribiríamos 5.50 + 1.25 S ≤ 15. Ahora
que hemos escrito esta desigualdad, ¿cuál es el
número de paradas que Keyla puede pagar?, ¿cuál
es el mayor número de paradas que puede pagar?
Pausa el video y trata de resolverlo. Bueno,
para resolverlo tenemos que calcular S y luego
calcular cuál es el mayor valor de S que satisface
la desigualdad una vez que hemos calculado S, y
así lo primero que haremos será restar 5.50 de
ambos lados. Cuando hacemos eso, nos quedamos
con 1.25 dólares S ≤ 950 , luego dividiremos
ambos lados entre 1.25, y como estoy dividiendo
ambos lados por un valor positivo no cambia la
dirección de la desigualdad, así que dividimos
esto entre 1.25 y luego dividimos esto entre 1.25.
9.5 / 1.25 = 7.6, de modo que obtenemos
que S ≤ 7.6. No podemos tomar un número
fraccionario de paradas, así que la mayor cantidad
de paradas que Keyla puede tomar serán 7 paradas,
ella no puede tomar 8 y no puede tomar
7 y medio o 7.6, así que el mayor número
de paradas que puede tomar son 7, ella puede
tomar 7 paradas como máximo. Y hemos terminado.